hello everyone I am running I'm visiting
the Goliath National Institute of
Science Education and Research
coordination
this talk is based on my recent
resection on identity testing and
non-conditive rank competition over the
free skill field
this is Joint work with celebration
So the plan of the talk is as follows
who will first introduce the rational
and interesting problem the main focus
of this work and then we'll briefly
mention our results of this word
whatever one
okay so let's start with some
introduction to rational identity
problem
before we uh tell you what is rational
and interesting problem let us go over
what is polynomial ion testing problem
okay so we are familiar with polynomial
identity this is everywhere in
mathematics and theoretical computations
and to check that this is an indeed
polynomial identities we can just uh
expand it more well by monomial and
check the coefficient such thing or not
are equivalently we can uh like only one
polynomial is given and we can check
whether the question for every model is
0 or not
but uh for multivate polynomial it can
have exponentially many monomials so it
is important how the polynomial is
represented to us so Atomic circuit is
used as an efficient representation of
multiviewed polynomials
so if you are familiar with Boolean
circuits you can think of it as an
algebraic analog of Boolean circuits
but the input nodes are leveled by
variables or Skillets from the
underlying field and the internal nodes
and the one designated output node
labeled by some basic arithmetic
operation like addition or
multiplication and in that output your
Computing the polynomial of your
interest
and similar to the Boolean setting if
the fan out of each internal node is at
most one then we call it an arithmetic
formula so just like electronic circuits
and electronic formulas the the other
computational model of our interest is
algebra currency program which is again
or written as a figure but this time the
edges are labeled by some
[Music]
and there is a designated Source node
and a designated sink node and if you
look at any source to think well it
computes the product of linear forms
depending on the linear from labeling
those edges
contributing participating in that part
and the final polynomial Computing is
like if you take the sperm over all
social source to think well uh this
product of linear form of product
obviously there as you can check in this
example this is the polynomial in
computer
okay
so now we can Define the p i t the
polynomial and identity testing problem
formally like
given a polynomial
given by an algebraic circuit or formula
and AVP we want to decide whether it is
counting a zero polynomial or not
okay so the PID problem is of two types
the first one is like white box where we
can we can see how the circuit is
Computing the polynomial then we can
exploit the sun instruction this is
called White walk algorithm and the
second one is Black Box Pi key where the
polynomial is given to us as an
evolution of vertical and our goal is to
find a non-zero Evolution and here we
are using the semantic meaning of a
non-zero polynomial if a polynomial is
non-zero then we know that there there
would exist a non-zero evaluation a
witness you can think of it as the
weakness of its non-zeroness
we will be able to find a non's
regulation and black was pit have to
find such a weakness so as in the Black
Box we can't see the polynomial so you
can think of like the bullish output the
list of evaluations so that for every
non-zero polynomial in that list of
Regulation you'll be able to find a
weakness of its non-zerrowness okay so
it's like a list that works for all the
polynomials so this list of Evolutions
is formally called a hitting set
so a healing set age
with respect to circuit clusterity is
defined as the list of evaluation so
that's what every non-zero polynomial in
the circuit plus b
by non-zero women that there is some
weakness
in the universe and will be able to find
a witness in that small list of
regulations in the healing set okay so
for example you can for to get some
intuition you can take this simple
example that when the circuit class is
like the polymers of all the invert
Polymers of degree atmosity then uh a
list of D plus one minute points it it
serves as a hitting set it is where it
is it okay and interactively you can
show that if instead of being invert
polynomial if you go to invert
polynomial of degree D you can construct
a heat instead of type D plus 1 over n
okay
due to polynomial identity dilemma it is
known that a commutative circuit uh we
can we can do Pit in randomized polymer
10 display box pit and deranimizing this
black box PID commutative pit is a
is an interesting open problem so this
is all about Community creating let us
now move to non-countered computation
and it computes non-complete polynomial
in the free algebra so now we can Define
non-communitive PID so in this case also
for non-tool computation also we can
Define non-commative circuit formula
non-commative ABP so uh given a
non-conditive polynomial by some circuit
AVP or formula the goal is to decide
whether it is Computing as zero
polynomial industry algebra or not so
how different is it from the competitive
setting you can get some idea from this
simple example like X1 X2 X1 plus x 2 x
1 minus x 2 is equal to X1 equivalent to
exclusive it is a polynomial identity in
commutative setting but it is not an
identity in the non-countered setting
because that monomials x 1 x 1 x 2 x 1
then I will cancel out each other but
now the Black Box pity becomes quite
free yes we have tinted for every now
you know polynomial there will be a
weakness of its normal but like if you
take the first one it's not an identity
in the non-communic setting but whatever
the value you substitute from the field
you will not be able to tell that it's
not an identity so now the idea is to go
to Matrix algebra so here we Define
Heating State as like
the list of Matrix evaluations
okay so for every non digital
non-community polynomial
there is a matrix to build a matrix
stimulation as a weakness of its
non-zerleness okay and the goal is to
find such a weakness so what is known
due to force in silicate is known that
if we have a non-countered quality no
matter we're not going to polynomial
competitive formula of policies then we
can construct a heating set of costly
polynomial page okay
okay so now we whatever we have
discussed we are using addition and
multiplication as basic arithmetic
operation
now suppose we are using division or
equivalently the input
so even the Commodities that will be
used
an investigate uh it computes with more
than one inclusive it concludes
commutative rational functions and
it has a canonical representation like
any commutative rational function can be
represented as a ratio of two Community
polynomials so if you want to test
whether a commutative pressure function
is zero or not it it essentially reduces
to commodity create
but in the non quantity setting when you
introduce inverse with then it becomes
very complicated
formally it Compares non-conditional
function
in the Universal prescription which is
quite well studied in mathematics for
several years so
formula what what is this non-communic
rational function so
um in this job we'll see uh different
definitions of non-communition function
right now let's start with the false
definition given by obviously
which the consider all non-founded
rational expressions okay and any two
expressions any two rational expressions
for every maastrix substitution whenever
both of them are defined it can happen
that one of them is depending but the
other one is not defined we ignore those
substitutions whenever both of them are
defined if they agree then we say that
these two expressions are completing the
same rational function
okay so you can think of like given this
set of all natural rational expressions
modulo this relation those equivalence
classes we call non-communitive rational
function
okay
and uh unlike Community setting here it
doesn't have any candle organization
like you can express it as like ratio of
two non-communitive polynomials that you
can't just expand it as like monogamous
so
um it is quite different from the
competitive setting and here also uh one
important parameter is that inversion
height the number of nested inverse if
you look at a path from Leaf to root how
many inverses uh are there okay so in
competitive setting as we have seen that
we can always express it as like ratio
to community poly organs we can push the
invert it at top of the it's the we can
actually think that there is only one
English circular formula but in case of
non-community setting the number of
nested inverses
um it's like how complicated the
rational function is it depends on the
number of nested inverses it has and it
was from the erosion we understand that
if we consider a size formula we can
bound and this initiative versus the
inversion height by the quarter log base
okay so Ruby semiculates will also
Define this rationalizing testing
problem that given a non-commuted
rational formula we want to decide
whether it is Computing the zero
function in the Universal phase
equipment or equivalently that does it
is a matrix substitution of some
Dimension where if we evaluate the
configuration formula
it is defined and it is not zero we want
to find such a point
so how non-trivial it is you can get
some idea from this simple identity
which is known as it was identity
we don't have any
um
any trivial algorithm to check that it
is the rational identity so what is
known about this problem
so
due to girl good with Olive Garden
it was shown that in iranistic
polynomial time we can solve rit in
white box later it was the extended over
finite tools also by even as our
subramanian
in Black Box for General irrational
formula we have a randomized polynomial
can algorithm due to personal marker
but uh we have a deterministic possible
time algorithm only for rational
formulas up to inversion and two
only the path level of necessing versus
recently in Azure 12 week are winning
and we showed that but the anomalization
of Black Box variety for General
rational formula is open
okay
so this is this is the state of the
heart and now let us start with our
first result the relation between
non-computative hardness and Rit and D
randomization
so
our goal is to deranimate the writing
and what we thought that can we reduce
this directly randomization problem
to proven lower amount to another
problem
which is like probably easier to develop
like you are one problem so the
intuition comes from the commutative
impaired due to the result of cabinets
and impact laser it is known that if you
can show the hardness of the permanent
polynomial it implies PhD television
okay so it is known that hardness
implies here randomization in
competitive setting what a non-countered
setting
it turns out that there is a similar
resulting uncountered setting also due
to work that up and we who showed that I
mean they can point out any single
polynomial but if you consider any any K
dimensional Matrix algebra and consider
the class of all polynomial identities
of the three dimensional Matrix
if the AVP complexity is exponential is
to power k for all the polynomial
identities then it implies der
randomization of non-commute formula and
non-confident to ABP
Okay so
it is quite reasonable now to Guess that
IIT will be able to De randomize the
idea also using some hardness assumption
you know the
interesting question would be to uh
pinpoint what will be the Assumption or
in other words
how much uh
we need to prevent do we need to
strengthen the hardness assumption to uh
get this rit in randomization
supposingly what we get that the same
hardness assumption suffice is 2D
randomize RIT also almost port
General rational formula so more
precisely what do you show the same
hardness assumption
would
show or give you what was the problem is
Heating State for rational formulas of
constant equation Act
and
for rational form of sizes and inversion
height log is by log log is we get a sub
exponential time algorithm so just
recall that so
it captures captures almost the entire
class of rational formulas
Okay so
the let us discovered the proof idea
of this result so it has two main
components the first one is a variable
reduction state
uh that given a rational formula in very
rational formula we come up with an
encoding such that the the first
property is that that the encoded
rational formula is only over 2 into h
plus one many variables and second
probability is then it presents identity
Okay so
this is the first step that we reduce
the number of variables preserving the
identity and the second step is that we
bound the dimension of the rewind point
if the
rational formula given rational formula
is the size is an equation at age we
showed that
it cannot be an identity for uh logs for
X plus one dimensional Matrix algebra
in in other words if you give me a
rational formula of psyches of inversion
age and if I substitute didn't exist
a weakness from this direction
okay uh to prove that we use the ideas
from Matrix coefficient realization
Theory which essentially allows matrices
to interleague between non-frontal
variables also
um in this general setting it was
extensively started in uh in this paper
done by quality in Matrix pollution
realization Theory and also in our
recent
where we showed this gossip polynomial
style feeding set for impression X2 okay
now using this two components what we
can now do given a rational formula in
vibrational formula of sizes and height
H we just we do Pit for the encoded for
the clean coated rational formula which
is like two to h plus 1 by 8 and where
we have uh we know that it is depend on
matrices of this sensation log
exploration
and
essentially welcome to commodity PID
where we have the degrees like
polynominally bounded and number of
variables are logarithmically bounded
but constant inversion rate that gives
us the possible
okay so this is the first result that we
have now let us move to invertibility of
matrices over the Facebook event and
let us first go over what is the
relation with the RIT problem that we
are different
so
as we have said that the rational for
the the rational portion can be defined
in different ways we we have seen the
definition given by our missile
the second divination will look at given
by cone would Define a non-founding
rational function that for every
non-portal rational function there is a
linear Matrix The Matrix they increase
the light Alpha connection to sulfur to
explain each entry and if you compute
its inverse over the place cube field
okay then that rational function is
computed as one of the entry of the
inverse of the linear Matrix
okay so but rules and migration showed
they they strengthen this definition by
showing that if the rational function is
computed by a rational formula of size
is then the corresponding linear
principle that you would look at
the side of the linear equation will be
at most to if
suppose we want to do RIT for the
rational formula
now we'll look at the corresponding
linear pencil
of R inverse okay it is known that if R
is if and only R inverse is different
okay
now what we will do that uh we'll check
whether the corresponding linear
velocity
correspond to R inverse whether the
linear vessel is invertible or not in
the prescripted okay that would tell us
whether R is 0 or not in the freeze
frequent so
this this problem is known as singular
problem
which you can think of like the
non-convenient version of eight months
problem which is like an interesting
open problem that captures the commodity
avpid
okay
so what is known about this problem
for RIT the the reasons that we have
mentioned
actually those results reduce Society to
singular problem and gives a
deterministic polynomial time for
singular given a linear Matrix to check
whether it is invertible or not in the
phase equipment
now suppose we want to study a singular
in more general setting why we don't
where we also allow some nonlinearities
in the matrices okay some polynomial
then what is known so in the same paper
bird could be switching early media they
showed that
it admits the deterministic polynomial
time algorithm
even when they increase the competitive
small non-countative formula
okay so the main idea that they have
they reduce this case to uh to come
deciding invertibility of a larger
linear Matrix okay so now the question
that we have is that can we journalize
it digitalized it up to when the entries
are completed by some non-communic
formula now suppose that entries are
completed by non-count it is ABP or even
non-printed rational formula what we
show that this singular problem it
animates the deterministic polynomial
box algorithm even when the inches are
computed by this non-communicities or
non-commutative rational formulas
the main idea that we have is again a
gadget Construction
that that reduces to this linear case
but the construction that we have is
quite different from the construction
that was mentioned in the previous paper
the main idea here what we use is that
if they increase the pump
it has a small linear tension
then then we can
it's kind of linear is the composition
idea then we can always construct a
larger linear Matrix such that the
invertibility of that input Matrix
follows from the invertibility of the
new linear Matrix okay
so this is the second result that we
have now let us move to our final result
uh characterization of linear filter
representation
so as I have mentioned that foreign
[Music]
Matrix you look at the inverse of it
photos
for an entry needs like exponential size
non-community formula there is an
exponential separation
but if you allow Russian circuit instead
of rational formula then each entry of
the universe can be computed by
qualified expression circuit so if you
consider these classes our operation
formula therefore or all those referral
functions that have small linear
representation NRC those are different
functions that are small restaurants so
the first one is the proper containment
and second one we know that this linear
represented representation this class is
contained inside Earth
now the question would like to ask can
be identified as circuit class that
would exactly characterize
the linear representation so uh if your
Pampered with a completely setting you
can think of like
that it is exactly similar to the
detrimental representation we knew the
determinal representation fits inside
formula and circuit and we came up with
this ABP model that exactly
characterizes the determinator
representation in non-commodative case
can we come up with some circuit layer
that exactly characterizes this linear
representation okay
so to do that first of all we can't
solve this problem
we are not able to solve this problem
but we make a partial progress in
solving this problem so what we do
we positioned we Define a new model but
before uh telling you that new model let
us go over the third definition of
non-profit rational function so it was
defined by government
rational function of height h
suppose you have a polynomial expression
where some of the variables you are
increasing by non quantity fractional
function of inversion and H minus 1.
this is the way to construct a
non-governmentation option of Phi th
this definition was given by Birdman
and the new model that we defined which
we call inversely distant rational R
square circuit
where this polynomial expression that we
have it is computed by a non-communitive
RQ circuit or equivalently by a non
quantity ABB okay
and whenever uh we are like composing
the we are replacing this variable by
some uh inductively built circuits of
height H minus one this will be
inversely designed those G1 universe and
GP in build they will be pure wasted
but you show that this class this
inversely designed question has to
Circuit it has a small linear pencil
okay so that puts it inside uh in
between the class of rational formula
and linear representation
moreover if we remove this inversely
digital restriction then the class sits
in between linear representation and
rational surgery
in this containment we know that out of
the first two countries one must be
proper but we don't know which one is
properly
Okay so
yeah
that's all
thanks for Reckoning